[Applause]
all right welcome back to Hannity and
tonight the Biden impeachment inquiry it
is heating up and heating up big time
the walls are now closing in we have a
major development tonight house
oversight committee chairman James comr
has now officially subpoenaed zero
experience Hunter Biden uh Joe's brother
James Biden and their business associate
Rob Walker for Testimony as his inquiry
now has gone to the next level and
joining us now he is the chairman of the
house over site and accountability
committee James comr is with us sir how
are you I'm well you know I I asked you
a while back I said at what point do you
think it's going to be appropriate to
start sending out subpoenas and you said
you wanted to get all your ducks in a
row you wanted to follow all of these
suspicious activity reports and all of
these um shell corporations follow the
money do you feel you you've got enough
information now that you have have some
pretty strong questions for these guys I
do I think we're at the point now where
uh we can connect the dots we understand
what the scheme was we understand who
the people were who were wiring the
money we believe we know why but we want
to hear from the bidens and uh we're at
the point now where the evidence is
overwhelming and now we can bring the
bidens in and ask them substantive
specific questions about things that we
have serious concerns about
how many shell corporations have you
been able to discover through your
investigation that the Biden family
had over 20 and you know when you talk
about James Biden I'm not sure exactly
what his businesses were uh but with
respect to Hunter uh we're we're
confident that these businesses did not
produce a good or service and we really
have no idea what they did uh especially
considering the fact that they would go
months without any revenue and then all
of a sudden a million dooll wire from a
foreign National would appear uh and
then the next day they would start the
laundering process where they would wire
money from account to account from Shell
company to Shell company uh you know we
see a similar pattern with Jim Biden but
we want to ask Jim Biden exactly you
know what did you do uh what what are
all these transactions in your so-called
business and what involvement did your
brother have in these Shady business
schemes let me let me go through the the
timeline of barisma we know that Hunter
admitted on GMA that he had no
experience in energy oil gas coal or
Ukraine um and he was paid millions of
dollars um couldn't explain why but we
have a timeline it became official Obama
administration policy in October of
2015 that that they felt that Ukraine
had made enough progress on the issue of
corruption that warranted the loan
guarantees a billion dollar to be is the
exact amount we know that 5 days before
Joe Biden in December of that same year
2015 went to Ukraine that Joe Biden got
on a phone call with his son Hunter and
barisma Executives uh we know this is
the time when barisma Executives were
begging for DC help then we know Joe
leveraged that $1 billion of taxpayer
money demanded the firing of the
prosecutor investigating barisma and his
son and fact the son of a bee got fired
in 6 hours and as a result Hunter
continued to get paid is that by
definition does that in your view meet
the bribery standards and bribery laws
of our
country absolutely and you look that's a
quidd proquo ironically that's what the
first Trump impeachment was all he did
was ask about the corruption we have the
corruption you just pointed it out the
timeline is there we have Joe wien on
tape admitting that he fired the
prosecutor when he threatened to
withhold our tax dollars so that
timeline is a huge concern to our
investigation we also have the timeline
with China with the
$40,000 that ended up in Joe Biden's
pocket that originated from the WhatsApp
message where Hunter threatened the
Chinese operative to to follow through
on the commitment they made while Joe
Biden was vice president let me let me
ask you though that WhatsApp message
said I am sitting here with my father
we're wondering why you didn't keep your
commitment and then saying we are
waiting for your call meaning Joe and
Hunter and Joe Biden had said he never
once spoke to Hunter or his brother or
anybody for that matter about any
foreign business deals but that app
message says that I'm sitting next to my
father why didn't you commit your meet
your commitment and between everybody he
he knows and my ability to keep a grudge
um you're going to regret not keeping
your word how many days later was it and
how much money was sent into the Biden
family confers and that by the way was
an energy company out of China y 5 days
later $5
million uh wired into a hunter Biden
Affiliated entity the next day he wired
$400,000 into the deal that uh we've
heard Tony balinsky and others say was
the deal where Joe Biden was going to
get 10% for the big guy that $400,000
wire a few days later ended up in a
40,000
check to Joe Biden exactly 10% for the
big guy so you so Joe Biden has a China
problem and he has a Ukraine problem now
we don't know a lot about doesn't he
have a Russia problem too because didn't
he meet with the Russian oligark at Cafe
Milano absolutely is a Russian how many
Biden family members got paid and how
many were grandchildren and do you know
of any work that any Biden ever did for
the tens of millions of dollars you've
identified well if you count Joe Biden
that's 10 Biden family members so nine
members uh excluding Joe the uh the only
two work that may have been involved
would have been Hunter and Jim Biden
that's why we're bringing them in first
uh the there was at least one grandkid
uh there were several nieces and nephews
at a very young age that were getting
wires from from foreign Nationals so a
lot of questions and we're at the point
now where you can connect the dots and
it's time to bring the bidens in and
that's why we issued the subpoenas today
all right we're looking forward to that
I will say this the one thing that
Hunter Biden has going for him he does
have a great lawyer he does have Abby L
Abby L is a serious attorney in DC um
and we'll see how he plays this my guess
is they're going to try my guess is my
bet is they plead the fifth James Abby L
Abby L is also representing mandez too I
want to make that point Point okay Point
made all right thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else